It was alleged that the newspapers were
not aware of the large percentage of the
population of American citizens were
unhappy with the ruling establishment,
did not feel their voices are being
heard,
and they voted against what everybody
thought was was the leading candidate
and instead voted for this rank
outsider,
a very unpredictable and generally
unpopular person.
Because businessman this egotist,
this rakish character named Donald
Trump.
I thought what was missing from the
newspapers,
and I think more than that from
Americans in general,
who watched television,
who read books to teach in universities
who are among the educated classes,
which go almost includes everybody these
days.
The reason I say that in my lifetime,
born in 1932 and becoming a journalist
in the 19 fifties and at the time I
became a journalist,
the 19 fifties we journalists,
whether it worked for the New York Times
and the Philadelphia Inquirer or the
Chicago Tribune,
where generally the first of our family
to have gone to college.
And when I say college,
I do not mean Harvard,
Yale,
Princeton,
Stanford.
I mean Brooklyn College or in my case,
the University of Alabama.
We were not going to the elite colleges.
If we went to college at all,
it was we were considered scholars in
our family,
but what we were,
what we were not true today,
but what we in the Mid Twentieth Century
America,
we were outsiders.
We journalists were of the outsider
class,
whether we were Italian heritage is me
or Jewish or African American or
Spanish,
whatever,
and we saw through the outside looking
in with our nose pressed against the
glass.
We looked inside at power and privilege
at maneuverings within the political
system,
at a poc,
cracy,
at outright deceit.
We saw all this and sometimes if we had
courage,
we wrote about and we did have courage
because most of us had come from parents
or grandparents who had knew,
who had firsthand knowledge,
persecution and foreign countries who
came to this country on the run and
brought with them the spirit of
unfairness and we as the inheritors of
their spirit when journalism.
We were the children of those period of
those people.
We brought not cynicism,
but skepticism of power and it was never
our ambition to be part of power because
we were chroniclers of power.
We were critics of power.
We were viewers of power.
We were outsiders.
Well,
those days are long,
long,
long gone.
Well,
we have now 50 years beyond what I'm
talking about,
the group of journalists who go to the
same elite schools as the most
privileged people have power.
Obama was a college professor,
Harvard Man,
and he was teaching while a president
for the two terms essentially teaching
class to the higher classes,
including the journalism of his time.
Now you have this ranking foul mouth
guy with his oldest awful blonde hair
becoming elected and the people in
general.
Oh God,
it's so embarrassing.
It's like they were so stunned is like
having a.
their.
Their world is shattered and have why
you're so shattered.
Why are you so stupid?
Don't you realize that you join you.
Journalists are so blind.
You don't know as journalist anything
except being educated from the time
you're.
You're privileged little kids.
I mean,
even poor people,
black people,
Hispanic,
still want to be like the privileged
white people and what I'm getting at,
and her long winded way is the way
journalists have failed,
were failed profession.
The pride that my generation took,
being strong as a force against the
powers of prerogative,
powers of privilege doesn't exist
anymore.
It doesn't exist anywhere.
The journalist now want to be part of
the power game.
They wanted to get on Air Force One.
They want to join trump at 21.
They want to have that dinner.
20 one with the.
They want to be clustered in Washington,
which is the most decadent city.
It's the most evil empire.
If I were running Washington,
boy do I sometimes have grandiose ideas
in the middle of the night,
if I was already what I would get half
of those reporters out of Washington,
break up the Washington press corps,
send them all over to the state
capitals.
We have 50 states,
put two reporters in every state instead
of covering congress or the cabinet or
whatever.
Let the people who are from these states
report the mood of the state's report.
The feelings,
the findings,
the personalities that are in parts of
America that are not and in the main
main street and main light,
and we tell our story not for the power
brokers that are clustered Washington,
those privilege power and generally rich
people,
but we're tell something about the
results of law,
the results of privilege,
the results of ignorance,
the results of,
of,
of bad decisions and war would cover.
Injured.
Soldiers would cover the life of,
of farmers,
would cover a grease mechanic and a guy
that's some redneck sheriff somewhere.
And if we knew the America that way,
we would not be surprised by such an
election as we had and the aftermath of
Obama's eight years.